my belief was that there's only three
objections that can come up on a sale
one is i need decision maker the second
was i need to think about it and then
third was price that's pretty much what
i preached for six seven years i now
feel like i've since learned a few more
nuances to it that have helped me a lot
and so there's four that are required
from the buyer and three that are
required from the seller and so that's
what makes the seven okay and so the
four from the buyer is something that i
learned from the software world which
they call band that's budget authority
need timing but if they do not have one
of those four they cannot close the deal
on the flip side what the buyer needs
from us is that they trust us for three
different things and this was different
from what i used to believe do they
trust that this product is going to
solve their needs in the way that they
want them to be solved because i mean
you might want to lose weight but you
might not want to do surgery or you
might want to lose weight but you not
might not want to exercise you might
just want to diet number one number two
do i trust me the sales person because
they might believe that but not trust
you which then influences whether
they're going to buy from you and then
the third is whether they trust the
company whether it's a scam or legit or
it's going to be here